say we are waking up this morning of
course the news that that letter has
been sent to Brussels requesting an
extension what's your reaction not very
prime ministerial but I think given the
behavior of remainders in Parliament
including the speaker
I think Boris Johnson has a right to be
pretty angry and the country is pretty
angry I mean just look at yesterday it
was built up to be Super Saturday and it
turned into an absolute flop and what
we've really seen now is over three
years of the establishment trying to
stop brexit and that's why the public
are so upset with their politicians and
Beyond brexit are gonna want real
political reform so where I'm a little
bit confused is you're talking about
that people will be upset at the idea
that's you know the cans being kicked
that the delay is happening but earlier
this week you said would I rather accept
a new European treaty that's frankly
very bad for us or would I prefer to
have an extension and a general election
I would always go for the latter option
so are you really saying you prefer to
extend article 15 delay brexit I mean
you're like a secret main sleeper agent
what's going on I want to leave on the
31st of October with a clean break
brexit that's the only brexit worth
having because the one that Boris
Johnson is put into the House of Commons
or tried to put yesterday and bounce
them into before anybody had actually
seen the content it's a new e u-- treaty
it binds us and it doesn't get brexit
done because all it does is take us on
to the next stage of negotiations and
Misha Barnea has outlined all of his red
lines it's all there in the political
declaration and we're gonna be headed
into another three years of agony so I
want to leave on the 31st of October but
you know I'll warn everybody if this
treaty goes through nothing would have
changed at all and I think far better to
have a short delay and a general
election where we might solve this
because we've got a leave country that
hasn't changed one little bit and the
remain Parliament and a general election
could just sort this out how can you say
that nothing would have changed if this
deal goes through will take us out of
the customs union would take us out of
the free out of the single market it
would give us control over
free movement of people it would allow
us to strike our own trade deals I mean
it may not be the brexit that you want
but it is a form of bricks that come on
well on the first of November if we were
to leave we wake up and with stood in a
single market and we're still inside the
customs union and we're still paying
money to the EU because the transition
right and the transition okay last up
until the end of 2022 it's a very very
long way away any form the end of 2020
isn't it well and we have to give notice
of extension by the 1st of July the
chances of us sorting this out in the
next six months are just about zero and
as I say you know even even when you
hear the Prime Minister saying we take
back our fisheries read the small print
you know have a look at what is being
demanded by Monsieur Barnea in terms of
the level playing field basically he's
saying that in terms of employment
legislation social protection
environmental law and even taxation we
are gonna have to be on a level playing
field with the rest of Europe which
means we're not taking back control of
our laws this is not brexit and all the
dilemmas that we faced in the last few
months we'll be back with them in May
and June next year a clean break is the
only way we're going to get a proper
brexit just want to kind of reinforce
eyes that the end of the transition is
at the end of next year you've already
said that you don't actually really mind
an extension if it means very little
happening I want a general election so
an extension for a few weeks into which
we can have a general election is a much
better outcome than signing up to a
treaty that becomes part of
international law that binds us in
foreign policy and in many many other
areas this is a rotten deal if Boris
jobs that have presented this six months
ago to the House of Commons the ERG
every man and woman would have voted
against it I do understand because of
brexit fatigue and anger in the country
the temptation to vote for it but it is
nothing more than brexit in name only it
will not solve anything
this will not end things in fact in many
ways as far as Brussels are concerned
we've just finished the easy bit
I just wonder if you were acknowledged
that potentially public opinion appears
to be shifting slightly there was a Hugo
poll out this week for example which
found that two-thirds of people who
voted to leave in the referendum now
what the deal passed compared to 10% who
say that impatient vote against it so
you on the losing side well actually if
you look overnight you'll find YouGov
poll showing nearly 50% of people have
no idea what is actually in and let's
not call it a deal let's call it a
treaty because that's what it is
and I spoke to a lot of MPs on Friday
and Saturday and because they've been
bounced into this they didn't know what
was actually in these documents I urge
everybody particularly those in the ERG
and Euroskeptics I'm a Labour Party
spend today reading and understanding
the extent to which these documents bind
us in for the next few years and you
realize this is not brexit and the agony
will continue last time we spoke a few
weeks ago miss raj he said that you
would consider a pact with the
Conservative Party at the next election
now you've seen the details of the deal
that Boris Johnson has negotiated would
you still be open to that kind of deal
well the point about a general election
is it would give the Prime Minister the
chance to press the reset button the
chance to say actually you know mrs. Mae
tried with this treaty
I've amended 5% of it I've got some
important changes on the Customs Union
but we still haven't got a package that
works and if Boris Johnson went to the
country having pressed the reset button
and said look it is either a simple
free-trade agreement or we're leaving
with a clean break brexit I think then
the prospect of building a brexit
alliance to fight the election is there
and you know something that would win a
very big majority in the next election
and then we could get a brexit rather
like the one we voted for I'm afraid
going down this route it isn't going to
happen do you think the brakes the party
could prevent a conservative majority
then if you don't have an agreement it's
difficult to say you know I remember
back in 2015 people saying to me as
leader of you keep well of course the
effect of you keep in the election is
that you'll damage the Conservatives and
health labour and actually we hurt the
Labour Party far more than the
Conservatives it is difficult to
estimate as I say I just hope we get the
chance to have a general election and I
want MPs please study the detail of this
realize it doesn't make us a free
country what would be a good night for
the brexit party at a general election
Oh who's to say who's to say well it's a
brand-new party we've never fought the
general election before we fought a
European election and we managed to get
the whole debate on the EU reset you
know if Boris did get this through the
public may well say hey that's great
we've got this over the line but once
they realize it's actually just mrs.
may's deal with a few improvements
they're going to be very very angry I
don't see any prospect of us getting out
before 2023 under these arrangements and
that frankly isn't good enough the
brakes that party might not for many
elections before but you've fought a few
in your time where are you planning on
standing as men I haven't decided yet
generally haven't decided I genuinely
haven't decided it's the long left well
there isn't even a short list or a long
list so I haven't decided what I'm gonna
do yet what I do want to do is to try
and educate people
please don't just take Boris's word for
it that it's a great New Deal it isn't
great very little of its new and it's
not a deal it's a binding international
trade see I haven't spent 25 years
campaigning for us to become an
independent country to swap one EU
treaty for another EU treaty